far cry 6 is set to take us to the
fictional island of yara to face
dictator anton castillo and his
oppressive regime and while it sticks
pretty closely to the far cry formula in
many ways there's still a lot of new
stuff to dig into here's everything you
need to know about far cry 6. for more
make sure to like this video and
subscribe
set in the present day far cry 6 occurs
in a time of great political turmoil
within yara as a country frozen in time
due to economic sanctions and
isolationism the population begins to
rise up against castillo's oppressive
regime
which has run on his ambition to rebuild
the country to its former glory when
yara becomes paradise
my methods
no one will care you'll play as danny
rojas a native yaran who was caught up
in the uprising to overthrow castillo
and free yara from the presidente's
control teaming up with a guerrilla
faction you'll explore urban and rural
areas of the island confronting
castillo's army and engaging in the
familiar open-world antics you'd expect
in a far cry game how was my day well i
followed a bloodthirsty rooster into
combat after he blew up a truck
another change coming to far cry 6 is
the return of the voiced protagonist who
will be present in cutscenes and have
more agency in the story than most other
far cry lead characters unlike many
other far cry protagonists who are often
outsiders making their way through a
foreign land dany has deep ties to the
island making their investment in its
future more personal you'll be able to
choose between a male or female dany and
far cry 6 will also feature moments
where the game transitions to a third
person perspective those moments won't
just be limited to cutscenes either
you'll see that pov shift when you use
your supremo backpack and when dany
enters friendly gorilla camps
ubisoft has described yara as its most
ambitious open world yet and it includes
a mix of jungles coastal towns farmland
and urban environments to explore the
latter of which is a rarity for the
series throughout the game you'll
acquire weapons gadgets and vintage
vehicles based on technology handed down
and recycled from decades past if all
that sounds like too much to handle by
yourself don't worry you can play in
co-op after completing the early game
mission do or die by and large far cry 6
doesn't deviate much from the loop and
gameplay experience of recent far cry
games this loop focuses heavily on
exploring your surroundings engaging
inside missions retaking outposts and
eliminating key members of castillo's
military to destabilize their control of
the island nation it's familiar and
still looks to capture those same
thrilling moments of open world hijinks
that you would expect from the series
however far cry 6 presents a bit more
flexibility with how you go about facing
off against castillo's regime one of the
more significant innovations in far cry
6 is the new weapon types which now
include three special categories of
firearms and gear the first type is the
regular variety which includes standard
pistols assault rifles and shotguns a
mix of recycled equipment passed down
from the cold war era along with modern
weapons stolen from castillo's army the
second type is known as the resolver
improvised weapons made up of junk items
and scrap along with the minigun there's
also a flamethrower and a disc launcher
that fires burned cd copies of the 90s
hit song the macarena
the final weapon type is supremos
specialized augmented backpacks that can
unleash super moves such as a back
mounted mortar launcher or rocket
powered jetpack furthermore all of these
weapons are customizable letting you
turn a simple handgun into a machine
pistol with a drum magazine complete
with a nice paint job and charm there
are also different ammo types that can
hit enemy weaknesses and take them down
much more easily player and loadout
customization has a deeper role in this
game than in earlier entries along with
the weapon augments you can also
customize your repurposed classic muscle
or town cars with different decals and
guns and even deck out dany with varying
options of clothing that offer bonus
perks such as increased stealth and
better weapons handling you can also
change the appearance of your gear and
keep its stats if you want to stealth is
much more viable as well you can even
holster your gun to hide in plain sight
and bribe roaming guards to avoid
engagements
christmas trees do you even grow those
here mexicans pay crazy money for this
how you think the president defunded
maria's new face
[Music]
returning from far cry 5 is the renamed
fangs for hire feature now it's called
amigos which allows you to partner up
with allies met in the main story one of
which is a crocodile named guapo while
all the amigos will be animals world
director benjamin hall confirmed that
the human element of the yara
insurrection would come from like-minded
people that will join the fight other
animals in the game can be hunted for
meat to trade and horses can get you
from a to b in a gif there's gonna be
plenty of dlc for far cry 6 coming over
the next few months in terms of free
content there'll be crossover missions
featuring rambo danny trejo and even
stranger things that you can play either
solo or in co-op there'll also be weekly
insurgencies that involve you tracking
down castillo's underlings to earn new
gear there's also going to be special
operations which take you to unique new
areas of yara and will introduce new
gameplay mechanics as you snatch highly
unstable chemical weapons from anton's
arms dealers and gets the extraction
point before it overheats if you buy the
season pass you can play as villains
from previous games including vas pagan
min and joseph seed to better understand
those characters you'll also receive a
copy of far cry blood dragon and weapons
armor vehicles and a new fang for hire
so there we have it everything you need
to know about far cry 6 before you delve
in for more on the game subscribe or
head over to gamespot.com where you can
also learn more about ubisoft's
employees taking action to change
hostile company culture and how the
company itself has responded i'm on
twitter at lucy james games and i'll see
you next time
you